all we have to do is enforce the laws
that are already on our books and secure
our borders
let's boy listen why do borders exist
yeah just stop this kind of crap from
happening by the way hit the
notification bell or join my club if you
haven't already full daily show
therefore people who are watching on
YouTube and subscriptions don't mean
anything anymore
so the question of the day where did you
first hear the news at Mollie Tibbets
that the killer was an illegal immigrant
and does that change the way you view
the story we'll get into some facts
statistics here in in this segment in a
little minute but on a personal level
does it change the context to a murder
when I was carried out by someone who
had no business being here at all
comment we want to hear from you
obviously in this tragic case now they
found her body if you don't know and an
illegal immigrant was charged with her
murder but the media is furious with
Trump's comments regarding the bag of
human scum you heard about today with
the illegal alien coming in very sadly
from Mexico and you saw what happened to
that incredible beautiful young woman
should have never happened
illegally in our country we've had a
huge impact but the laws are so bad the
immigration laws are such a disgrace I
don't that's one of those deals how
could anyone disagree with what he just
said yeah he said nothing inflammatory
he didn't say anything to try to rile
people up that being said there is
something singsong about the way he says
it we're like is there an insult in
there mrs. Purdy was a beautiful woman
like wait is he does he insulting
someone because we've been conditioned
to think that everything he says is bad
here's the thing there have been many
cases where illegal immigrants have
killed US citizens remember was at Kate
Kate Steindl yeah that was one remember
there were there's ever been tons we've
covered them on the show in contrary to
when a white guy shoots up a public
gun-free zone the media jumps on a
fashion a duck on a junebug unless of
course at what guy stopped by another
white guy when they are 15 Sen Willeford
nowhere to be found the ones by the most
deadly shootings in modern history more
so than parkland but nobody talked about
it yeah every time something like this
happens to leftist media trots out
articles claiming that the vast majority
of illegal immigrants there they're
actually law-abiding this is what we
have to deal with and you see this a lot
right and you've actually you've covered
this quite a bit yeah I cover a lot of
the European illegal immigration because
obviously at a far greater rate than the
American levels right now but it's it's
real bad there you're having people run
down in the street constantly just in
the UK what's fun is when I say the
majority of illegal immigrants are
law-abiding to those of you confused at
the redundancy seeming redundancy of
law-abiding illegal shut up you're
racist it's oxymoron and societal
nomenclature that we accept like you
know it's like jumbo shrimp or CNN news
it's just one of those deals that you
just go with let's take a closer look
though at the studies that were cited by
good old Washington Post we fact Jeff
gun by the way with lead or not too long
ago you can go watch that video I think
it was like nine hundred and fifty facts
they completely lied about so one of the
studies that they actually cite here it
just compares crime rates and locations
with more illegal immigrants with those
that have less so another study too that
they cite it assumes that if illegal
immigrants commit crimes at the same
rate as a legal population that there's
no increase in crime these are flawed
study well if this is one of the most
simple logical fallacies to the point I
even hate to point it out for fear of
sound like a first year social studies
students actually true but I know I know
and recuse cancer we get it okay course
that's equal causation okay you listen
to your professor for a few minutes
between weed naps but we all know for
example that very violent like like
Baltimore or Chicago's innocent they
don't have as high of an illegal
immigrant population compared to say
Dallas which may have less crime and a
higher illegal immigrant population so
that's what they're using when they're
citing these studies the question isn't
whether all cities with higher illegal
immigration would have higher crime
rates than those that don't
the question that needs to be asked and
this is like you said they can they can
torture the data and this is how you
know that it's a system they
systemically at a systemic level they
are absolutely doing that the question
is whether ill agglomeration has
resulted in an increase in crime in
cities like Dallas and the truth is is
actually really easy to answer I know it
seems complicated because violent crime
has consistently been on a downward
trend despite what the conservative
media tries to tell you that it's worse
never actually violent down
significantly and with a big city there
are a lot of variables but let me make
this simple for you every single crime
committed by an illegal immigrant is a
crime that could not have happened if
that illegal immigrant
wasn't here illegally period that seems
pretty self-explanatory hundred crimes
in Dallas committed by illegal
immigrants take away the illegal
immigrants enforce the laws in the books
that's a pretty good a math everybody
can jump I don't know why does the left
not admit this what this is what was so
crazy to me what's happened to all of
their rhetoric like with anti-gun the
anti-gun rather if it would all just one
one life there's even one step we can
take i'll save another child it's guy or
another parent i where's the tear or
another town not you two
from the grief that's visited Tucson and
Aurora a we can Oak Creek and Newtown
but Chicago every day in communities
from Columbine to Blacksburg before that
surely we have an obligation to try if
our actions result only saving one life
they're worth taking I gladly did this
gun up if only there was something we
could do if it would save only one life
okay but here's one that would save
anything you don't have to remove
someone's constitutional rights in fact
all you have to do is enforce the law it
would almost seem like a win-win for
legal immigrants and everyone else it's
really eating illegals it's crazy to me
to look at like the coverage or
something like Charlottesville bill
where the left says this death is so
obviously wrong we're gonna spend four
months covering this and talking about
there's no excuses nothing they would
never bring up data like let's look at
black lives matter crime versus KKK time
they would never bring that up in a
million years but when it comes to
illegal immigration every statistic in
the book tried to they try they try to
throw them all in the same pot legal and
yeah my mother's like these same people
plenty people people who work for us who
are legal immigrants right not the same
at all by the way I do want to clever
sure let's fill running someone over
dodge charger bad we all
yes but it is it is interesting how they
this is like my god rich like no one no
one in Texas knew about the Sutherland
Springs shooting yeah and we you know we
had Stephen Wilford on here who is got
the of the ar-15 it was more deadly than
parkland no one in Texas they were two
hours from where it occurred had heard
about it because it got about in two
hours of news coverage yeah because it
doesn't fit the narrative well he was a
instructor who took him out yeah that's
like Don lemons worst nightmare it's
like a teleprompter for Al Sharpton by
the way similar similar study has been
pushed as evidence that illegal
immigrants commit less crime than the
native-born population so here's
something that's important this study
actually includes legal immigrants so
they don't see the problem when you look
is is any surprise that illegal
immigrant the kind of person want to go
through the arduous process it is
difficult and I'll give you that we may
need to streamline this process coming
here legally and being so grateful to be
here that'll be the best behavior
because they don't want to be deported
that they're less likely to commit
crimes does anyone else see the problem
with including this study to say illegal
immigrants are less likely than the
general population to commit crimes when
you're including those people yeah can
it only is it me it's amazing how they
shift the goalposts repeatedly they
start with these are rocket scientists
and Harvard graduates coming over your
borders and then when that doesn't work
cuz people see obviously that's not the
case they're like oh these are refugees
they're escaping crime you have to save
them right then when people see that's
not the case they're migrants but they
love this all indica they use this that
this statistic that is being pushed this
is the one that is primarily used by
news media and by the way just like we
talked about with the wage gap you don't
believe that that Don Lemon or Barack
Obama they don't have access to Google
they don't know that it's a myth they're
lumping in illegal immigrants and legal
immigrants that's that's why it seems
confounding it's that's it's like
lumping legal gun owners in together
with the Crips it's just not a valid
comparison they seem incredibly
surprised they're not happy about it by
the way legal gun owners are one of the
most law-abiding demographics in the
United States yes illegal gun owners by
definition the least it's almost an
apples to apples comparison here's
another truth for you there are plenty
of studies which have repeatedly by the
way debunked this idea that illegals are
less likely to commit crime so illegal
immigrants actually fill prisons I want
to make sure I get this right on
between 3.5 to five times as many crimes
as the average native so one report this
comes from Heritage actually found the
criminal aliens make up 27 percent of
all federal prisons judging by those
numbers and federal prisons alone
non-citizens commit federal crimes at
three times the rate she citizens a 2001
study that actually does take country of
origin and geographic concentration into
account found that Mexican immigrants
it's like it's almost become a dirty
word if you're referring to immigration
you use the word Mexicans right I can't
believe you said in Mexico it's like
it's a slur now people of Mexico Mexico
I don't know Mexican immigrants commit
between 3.5 and five times as many
crimes as the average native to you have
these countries with extremely high
crime and you take a scoop of people and
throw them into your country you're
gonna get a crime over so you have to be
discriminatory yeah absolutely do I mean
this is what you're building a kind of
certain potently well what about
brilliance you're tired you're at a
certain point you do have to say all
right all right we're filling up here
and now we're going to have some
standards as to who is allowed into this
country that's it yeah that's it's
really that simple there are only about
seven percent of the population by the
way illegal immigrants commit twenty two
percent of the federal murder
convictions I were just talking murder
eighteen percent of fraud convictions
thirty three percent of money-laundering
conviction is twenty nine percent of
drug trafficking 72 percent of
convictions for drug possession so when
you read about Molly Tibbets and they
subsequently read all the leftist
apology tours claiming that it's an
isolated incident just called the Essen
get mad it's not an isolated incident
it's not true it's not accurate they
trot out one step that lumps everybody
in together and when you actually look
this is the beauty of the Internet it
for all of the D platforming that's
going on what's happening with social
media and hopefully the pendulum will
swing the other way when when CNN's
Anderson Cooper goes out and simply
cites a study you can look it up it
usually takes about two or three pages
to see that they're lying ya know it
doesn't take very long at all and you
should get extremely pissed off because
all of this is being done for votes this
is not like people don't understand how
to fix the problems they're doing this
to divide people to drive wedges between
people and to get your vote that's why
people are being murdered by illegal
immigrants that it shouldn't be in the
country in the first place right there
boats it's good point use I just got a
chill down my spine
I do it I can't really really do that
down it's sounds positively dark the
good thing by the way is it unlike the
less rhetoric board we could if we could
just save one child which and they use
that as an excuse to ban all firearms
and no proof that it would work by the
way in this case we do have the moral
hydrant you have the moral high ground
anyone out there who says alright okay
listen I think we need to actually take
a look at immigration laws or at least
enforce them we can say if immigration
enforcement could save just one life
whose life Mali Tibbets and countless
other lives that make up the statistics
that we've just shown you in the case of
immigration enforcement we don't have to
pay anything to save anybody you don't
have to take the 357 off of grandma's
shelf to ensure that someone is safe all
we have to do is enforce the laws that
are already on our books and secure our
borders borders which by the way have
existed since the beginning of time with
every single nation at one point or
another precisely to stop precisely let
me ask okay let's boy listen why do
borders exist yeah just stop this kind
of crap from happening that's the only
reason they're there and by the way they
tend to work hey there YouTube viewer if
you like this video I would say
subscribe hit the notification bell or
watch one of these videos playing in a
box that we've personally uploaded in
program for your viewing pleasure the
problem is now in today's day and age on
YouTube in 2018 any of those three
things that you do any of those three
buttons that you click will take you
directly to a Seth Meyers video so stay
here and join monk get off of here go to
lot of credit accomplished mug club it's
the only safe place you can go enjoy